[Música]
saberespoder todos hemos escuchado esa
frase pero no siempre nos detenemos a
pensar la importancia que tiene nuestras
vidas todos tenemos hambre de poder
siempre queremos más llegar más alto
queremos mejorar pero también tenemos
sed de conocimiento siempre queremos
saber más saberlo todo saber lo primero
es lo que nos trajo hasta aquí a este
evento y es lo que nos ha formado como
sociedad que ahora nos llaman la
sociedad del conocimiento no importa
nuestra profesión física química
matemáticas biología astronomía
estudiarlo todo saber el origen del
universo saber si hay otras cosas a ver
si hubo algo antes saber si hay algo más
nos gusta también estudiar la historia
saber de nuestros antepasados entender
cómo hemos evolucionado aprender de
nuestros fracasos para no repetirlos
pero también nuestros éxitos para
mejorarlos
estudiarlos como sociedad cómo nos
unimos y cómo nos dividimos el término
de redes sociales que está tan de moda
ahorita existió desde mucho tiempo antes
que hubiera tablets celulares
computadoras y gadgets esas redes
sociales estaban formadas por personas
por tribus por indígenas y ahí realmente
las decisiones que se tomaban eran
trascendentales ahí agregar a un amigo
borrarlo bloquearlo o ponerlo en acceso
restringido
realmente era trascendental tanto así
que es lo que creó el mundo como lo
conocemos hoy los países las ciudades
los asentamientos y eso lo estudia la
geografía
estudiamos la economía y las finanzas
los mezclamos con matemáticas modelos
computacionales probabilidad estadística
y lo que intentamos es predecir crisis o
prevenir caídas en la bolsa o también a
veces la utilizamos para hacer mucho
dinero el problema es que a veces lo
hacemos a costa de otras personas y es
ahí donde esa delgada línea entre el
bien y el mal del uso de la información
empieza a cobrar sentido toda la
información que existe puede beneficiar
a alguien pero también puede
perjudicarla y entonces la información
empieza a cobrar valor
las redes sociales ahora sí las
digitales las que todos usamos según
datos oficiales el 99 por ciento de los
mexicanos que tenemos acceso a internet
tiene al menos una red social 5 en
promedio bastante más que los libros que
leemos al año esas redes sociales han
generado la base de datos más grande que
jamás había existido la más rica del
mundo y la hemos generado todos nosotros
desde la comodidad de nuestros
dispositivos móviles estamos súper
preocupados del internet de las cosas
que viene que todo va a estar conectado
a internet pero no nos damos cuenta que
este es el internet de las personas
todos nosotros somos un sensor en
potencia y estamos generando información
hasta en este momento al estar aquí pero
esa información que estamos generando
está yendo a algún lugar y el problema
es entender a dónde está yendo y todo lo
hacemos a través de nuestro dispositivo
móvil nuestro teléfono inteligente que
yo más bien le llamaría teléfono
chismoso ese teléfono que tienen ustedes
en la bolsa sabe si están dormidos por
cuando ponen las alarmas saben si están
enojados o contentos por lo que publican
donde están por su localización y sabe
con quién están porque en este momento
todos estamos mandando la misma
ubicación es más el teléfono sabe que
estamos enfermos porque nada más
sentimos un síntoma y google amos cuánto
tiempo nos queda de vida y así se
enteran de las cosas
el problema es que nuestro teléfono está
chismoso sean dos información a alguien
que no sabemos que yo más o menos me lo
imagino así un zombi hambriento de
nuestra información cuál es el mejor
ejemplo de lo que hacen los zombis con
nuestra información el marketing cada
vez que posteamos algo chateamos o ahora
con whatsapp hacemos videollamadas nos
están analizando para ver si requerimos
algo cuántas veces nos ha pasado que
publicamos algo sobre un viaje y nos
empiezan a llegar ofertas de todos lados
tenemos que reconocer que eso a veces
funciona a veces tenemos acceso a cosas
que no tendríamos de otra forma si no
nos analizarán como lo están haciendo a
mí por ejemplo me están llegando todavía
ofertas de carriolas pero mi hijo está a
punto de usar mi coche tiene sus errores
otro error por ejemplo son las personas
que conocemos cada cinco minutos que nos
llaman para que nos cambiamos de línea
telefónica aunque sea la misma compañía
que ya teníamos o para darnos los
beneficios de los bancos de dónde sacan
nuestra información de dónde sacan
nuestros teléfonos
hasta nosotros podemos hacer mal uso de
los datos las redes sociales usadas pues
nos pueden servir para estar en contacto
con familiares y amigos nos pueden
servir para estar en contactos con
colegas y colaborar de forma profesional
pero también las podemos usar para mal
ustedes saben cuántos problemas ha
causado el poder saber cuál fue la
última hora de conexión de la otra
persona saber a qué hora se durmió o si
fue a la fiesta o no
el saber quién le da like a tus fotos o
peor aún saber a quién le das to light
en las fotos eso también causa problemas
y lo peor ha sido las palomitas del
whatsapp
puedes mandar un mensaje y saber que no
llego saber qué llegó y no te leyeron o
peor aún saber que te dejaron en visto
nosotros también podemos hacer mal uso
de la información que nos está dando
esta a este avance tecnológico que
tenemos a mí por ejemplo me hubiera
encantado saber si alguien tenía un
estacionamiento disponible para que
cuando yo llegué aquí hay que perder el
tiempo
buscando un parking de estacionamiento
pero eso me hubiera dado información
adicional de ustedes también hubiera
preferido saber si alguien venía del
norte de la ciudad y pudiéramos
compartir vehículos pero también me
hubiera dado información de ustedes pero
qué tal si quiero ir más allá y quiero
saber si alguien de ustedes va a tomar
un viaje va a tomar un avión a la ciudad
de méxico- acabando el evento y se
podría llevar un paquete un documento
que me urge entregar también yo podría
saber que van a dejar sus cosas su casa
sola por determinado tiempo
qué tal si yo quisiera saber su
profesión por si alguien se siente mal
saber si hay un médico en la sala y
pudiera atender cualquier emergencia
qué tal si yo quisiera saber dónde viven
todos ustedes para poder planear cómo
vamos a desalojar el recinto y reducir
el impacto ecológico
o más allá qué tal si yo les pidiera
acceso a todos sus datos en sus
teléfonos móviles y les dijera que
gratis les voy a hacer un análisis
psicológico para buscar patrones que me
puedan ayudar a prevenir suicidio
adicción a drogas violencia
intrafamiliar acoso bullying etcétera me
darían acceso a sus datos estoy seguro
que nadie me daría acceso a sus datos
pero qué tal si les digo que si me dan
esos mismos datos yo les voy a decir a
qué personaje de la televisión se
parecen
o cómo se vería a su hijo con angelina
jolie y brad pitt
o algo mucho más importante a qué
escuela de hawass van a pertenecer
entonces todos me darían sus datos ni lo
pensarían el problema no son los datos
que me den el problema en este momento
es a dónde se están yendo esos datos
porque esos datos están llegando a un
lugar y es tan barato en este momento
almacenar datos que pueden estar ahí por
años lo que publiquen hoy puede salir a
la luz dentro de 10 15 20 ó 30 años
y todas estas empresas lo que están
haciendo es esperar el momento adecuado
para poder generar dinero con su
información entonces tenemos que tener
cuidado con lo que publicamos les voy a
poner otro ejemplo yo en el doctorado
estuve trabajando con reconocimiento
facial me encanta esa área es muy
sencillo que una computadora pueda
identificar una persona solo por verla
como lo hacemos los humanos el proceso
consiste en tres pasos una base de datos
con fotografías de personas a reconocer
un algoritmo que es el que tiene que
tomar la decisión y luego unas pruebas
que determinan si el algoritmo es bueno
o malo si es bueno pues lo vende solo
públicas y si es malo pues no hay nada
que hacer un ejemplo rápido dos
fotografías un hombre y una mujer pues
el algoritmo sería muy sencillo
simplemente si tiene barba es juan y si
no es maria pero para hacer un algoritmo
más complicado hicimos una base de datos
de 300 personas 300 personas que
tuvieron que ir varias veces a tomarse
una fotografía con maquillaje sin
maquillaje con barba sin barba etcétera
para poder mejorar el reconocimiento
esta base de datos costó alrededor de
nueve mil euros más o menos 600 pesos
por persona
un buen algoritmo se pudo vender pero no
llego a más que pasaría si yo quisiera
hacer el mejor algoritmo del mundo
necesitaría una base de datos mucho más
grande imagínense una base de datos de
2.000 millones de personas cuánto podría
costar esa base de datos
se acuerdan cada vez que ustedes
etiquetar a una persona fotografía en
facebook
pues ustedes regalaron esa base de datos
y a facebook le dieron la base de datos
más grande del mundo y fue capaz de
hacer el mejor algoritmo de
reconocimiento facial del mundo que se
llama deep face les tocó algo de ese
algoritmo tienen su crédito o algo
regalamos los datos y lo vamos a seguir
haciendo porque muchas veces es
necesario para usar nuestro teléfono
para entrar a algún lugar alguna
promoción para usar una aplicación pero
lo que tenemos que hacer es tener
cuidado de que compartimos les podría
dar mil consejos nunca sacará una
fotografía de su tarjeta de crédito
fotos de sus hijos fotos de sus casas
donde se puede identificar la dirección
pero más que nada hay que entender el
concepto de qué está pasando con lo que
estamos compartiendo por un lado si no
vamos a leer ningún contrato de las
plataformas en las que nos inscribimos
entonces hay que tratar de compartir
pocas cosas porque no tenemos ni idea de
dónde va a llegar la información si por
otro lado nosotros vamos a leer
cuidadosamente todos los contratos
entonces somos capaces de compartir más
cosas porque sabemos perfectamente a
dónde van a llegar
tenemos que ver internet como una
ventana enorme hacia nuestras casas
donde cualquiera puede asomarse y
nosotros vamos a decidir si lo que vamos
a dejar ver es una habitación
desarreglada con ropa interior arriba
del escritorio o queremos que vean que
vean algo que nos representa más un
escritorio limpio un cuarto limpio y si
entendemos ese concepto no vamos a tener
problemas ni dudas de lo que queremos
compartir
y finalmente si vamos a seguir regalando
esta información y nos importa yo de
verdad los invito a acercarse a centros
de investigación donde investigadores
están haciendo cosas para mejorar la
sociedad y necesitan de sus datos
algunos ejemplos pues buscar factores de
problemas de salud mental en
adolescentes a través de cómo escriben
en redes sociales a qué horas lo hacen
de sus patrones cuestiones de movilidad
si sabemos de dónde van ya dónde vienen
si sabemos dónde estudian dónde trabajan
podemos mejorar la movilidad de las
ciudades hacer programas que mejoren el
transporte público lo mismo con
migración si sabemos dónde están los
puntos de abuso si detectamos las
denuncias podemos hacer programas y
políticas públicas que los apoyen y que
nos ayuden a mitigar todo lo que está
pasando en cuestión de derechos humanos
en seguridad pública si podemos detectar
dónde hay problemas donde hay asaltos
donde hay falta de seguridad también
podemos mejorar y buscar puntos rojos
hacer mapas de riesgo para que el
gobierno ponga más atención a ciertas
áreas
el estado de ánimo podemos detectar
síntomas tempranos de depresión que nos
permitan el prevenir suicidios el
prevenir adicciones y lo podemos hacer
simplemente con información que ustedes
generan todos los días lo mismo en casos
de bullying si tenemos contacto con los
padres de familia con los niños podemos
ver cómo se comunican cómo se ilustran
podríamos detectarlo porque esto no es
espionaje y no crean que nos interesa si
sus bebidas las prefieren de la marca
azul o de la marca roja o si sus
hamburguesas las prefieren de un rey o
de un payaso tampoco nos importa si su
casa es grande o tienen una casa chica
lo que nos importa es la sociedad porque
nuestra sede conocimiento nos ha llevado
a entender de dónde venimos y adónde
vamos y ahora lo que nos falta es saber
cómo evitarlo
muchas gracias